okay so super Suns is like kind of the
best thing coming out of DC rebirth
right now this story is amazing and it's
and it's so cool because I love the idea
of like Jonathan Kent and Damian Wayne
of like Superman's son and Batman's son
teaming up because all they do in this
story is bicker that's it that's all
they do is bicker with each other and it
is amazing it is it is so cool to see
but it also kind of highlights the
strengths and weaknesses of each of the
individual characters and it doesn't in
a way that it all kind of comes together
and it all creates this really a fun
story and that's what makes super son so
interesting it's just fun like it's just
good old-fashioned fun comic book
storytelling so initially we pick up
with with Jonathan Kent on his way to
school and again this is really just
kind of like a reflection of everyday
life which is kind of what you have to
do with super sons but it's not Justice
League right like you can't just have
them fighting one group you know from
from story to story you know that the
characters in the Justice League are
well established I mean the flash you
know Green Lantern are really the Green
Lantern's
as summoned as and Jessica Cruz Superman
Batman Wonder Woman so on and so forth
they are all established characters we
don't need to know the intricacies of
their everyday lives because we have
their own solo books for that but
there's no super you know Superboy's
solo book there's no Damian Wayne solo
book I would read them but there is no
book that's out there right now but for
those individual characters cuz you've
got to kind of put things in the
perspective in a way that it gives us an
idea of what they stand for and super
Sons is a great way to do that
now we know just by virtue of being the
son of Superman and we know by virtue of
the stories that he's been in both in
the Superman comics and in the action
comics Electronics kind of a weird
phrase that the Jonathan Kent is very
much standing up for the right thing
standing up for people who can't stand
up for themselves doesn't like people
being picked on especially when it comes
to snowball fights and they start
throwing snowballs at people with rocks
inside they're literally just don't
snowball folks but rocks inside we used
to do that back when I was younger it's
kind of a it's something I'm ashamed to
admit but we used to do that there was
one time I was in high school I'll never
forget there was one time I was in high
school there was this guy named coach
Doc Herman and I got was a dick but he
was he was the safe teacher and he was
walking who was walking into the
classroom when or walking into the
lunchroom one day and somebody hit him
in the back of the head with a snowball
this guy turned around he was so pissed
he was so mad he was absolutely amazing
but but anyway
so with regards to this to this story
that's a super Sun the cool thing about
this is that we also get the ingenuity
of Damian Wayne and what we end up
finding out is that Damian Wayne has not
only been masquerading as the bus driver
of the other kids that ride to school
with John McKenna
but he's also been masquerading as a
substitute teacher and that's kind of
the crazy thing right like it's kind of
a crazy scenario and so the funny thing
about this is that we also end up
finding out that they're basically
sneaking out now they're not supposed to
be this will be going to bed they're
supposed to be calling it a day but it's
really Jonathan Kent who's kind of
corrupted by the influence of Damian
Wayne in the sins of Jonathan's gonna go
to bed he's going to call it a day
he's very wholesome very grounded a kid
that doesn't really break the rules but
Damian Wayne popping up is basically
saying hey look there is an
investigation that's going on that I'm
doing there's been some break-ins you
know I want to go check it out you
should come with me now intrude in terms
of why it is that Damian Wayne brought
Jonathan Kent we don't know and in fact
we don't find out but I would surmise as
smart as Damian Wayne is he is toying
with the idea of potentially enrolling
Jonathan Kent into the teen titans which
by the way if Jonathan kid joined the
Teen Titans it would be amazing if you'd
make that book just so much more
interesting I mean it's already amazing
it make it even better
um but once you talk a little bit more
about that as we get to this story
because that's kind of what ends up
happening but the two of them basically
sneak out and it's kind of funny because
Jonathan doesn't want to hear well he
doesn't want to speak out of his house
but of course Damian gets them to do it
and they end up travelling over to
LexCorp
now this is one of the cool things about
this story this is one of the things
that I love so much it's Tomas he treats
the superhero community as a family in a
lot of ways right I mean the Justice
League are very much a family and like
well the Suicide Squad is as close to a
family as you can get what do you have a
bomb plan in your head and Amanda
Waller's starting to blow it up and kill
you if you don't do as she tells you to
so I guess they're kind of a family to a
degree but in terms of how some honestly
puts everything together all the
superheroes are more or less a family
and that's what we would expect right I
mean we would expect you to play out
that way they have their own issues they
have their own groups you've got
Batman's you know Justice League of
America you've got the Justice League
you know we'll probably have the Justice
Society somewhere along the line and
that was even a big mantra under Jeff
Jones you know the Justice League is a
strike force the Justice Society is a
family the idea is that if it really
hits the fan all the superheroes will be
there for one another and the way that
he plays on this is with the
introduction of lex luthor as superman
remember during the last days of
superman or i guess following the final
days of superman the death
the new 52 Superman the new frigate to
Lex Luthor stood up and took its place
as Superman in his mind when a classic
Superman showed up he was considered to
be a false Superman Alexa Lee they
looked at him and said no he's not the
Superman that I've known for all these
years the new 52 Superman is the one
that I know he's the one that's dead I'm
going to carry on his mantle again this
all harkens back to forever evil it all
harkens back to that story that
transition Lex Luthor from being a bad
guy to being a good guy and so because
of that one of the funny things that
happens here is what he encounters
Jonathan Kent and Damian Wayne his
question is like it's a school night why
are you guys here now of course the
funny thing is keep in mind Lex does not
know the truth about Damian or or
Jonathan you know as far as he's aware
they're just a couple of kids here now
I haven't read that far into life
forever evil and I haven't paid that
much attention to Lex Luthor but I would
have to believe that somewhere along the
line he became aware of Damian Wayne and
who Damian Wayne is with the very least
he probably knows you know who the
character of Damian is but he may not
know that Damian is Robin I mean again
Tomasi kind of plays it fast and loose
and it's fun I mean it works for what it
is it doesn't create massive continuity
errors or anything like that it just
kind of asked a couple questions here
and there but regards to the story and
for me that's one of the things that
kind of keeps the narrative going is the
idea of asking questions okay around the
bed kind of saying hey look is this
where this fits in or is that where this
fits in or something along those lines
you know it's just one of those those
cool scenarios when it comes to
storytelling but suffice it to say what
is up happening here as Damian Wayne
basically uses Superboy as a distraction
and again this is really really cool
because you essentially because you know
Jonathan Kent can't fly yet and so he
basically kind of knocks Jonathan Kent
off the building Lex Luthor has to
rescue him and in the interim Damian
Wayne goes into Lex Corp and starts
poking around now again this is the cool
thing about Damian because Damian is in
a lot of ways just as capable as Batman
and that's really the crux of this story
that's the crux of this narrative
throughout DC rebirth if you're reading
you know that Detective Comics if you're
reading Batman if you're reading
Nightwing you know if you're reading
super Sons the idea is that Damian Wayne
is trying to prove that he should be the
successor to the Batman mantle once
Bruce Wayne retires
that's his whole stance and that's
something that DC is kind of teasing
with that's something that Tom King you
know that the opinion that's something
that II see as a whole is is teasing
with and kind of toying with following
the events of the button right
if you remember if you saw our video on
the button you'll find it down in the
description Batman Bruce Wayne had
talked to his father Thomas Wayne from a
different universe and Thomas Wayne said
stop being Batman go be Bruce Wayne
raise your son have a life and the
implication was that at the end of the
button that Bruce Wayne was not going to
be Batman anymore which begs the
question if that's the case who's going
to take over the wall now we know he's
grooming like Duke for something in
particular Duke of course is the
character who's largely prominent and
all-star Batman but the fact remains
here the possibility is there that
Damian Wayne could take over the mantle
and if I'm going to be honest with you
guys I think he's the best person suited
for it if I were going to pick a person
who was going to take over the Batman
mantle once Bruce Wayne leaves
I would pick Damian Wayne any day of the
week Dick Grayson has already been
Batman Tim Drake is dead as far as
Batman and all those guys are concerned
you've already got Barbara Gordon
Batgirl you've already got hate Kane or
whatever it is a bat woman you've
already got a litany of characters who
are solidified in their own roles the
last remaining Robin is Damian Wayne
give it to him that's my stance I'm
curious what's your all stance on that
who would you make the next Batman if
Bruce Wayne retires who has you put in
that position but the fact remains here
that once Lex Luthor tracks down Damian
and begins to question him Damian Wayne
just really kind of toys with the idea
but he's got bombs planted all
throughout the the private laboratory of
Lex Luthor in his own LexCorp building
now of course using this as a
distraction
Damian and Superboy effectively just
bail out and so we actually won't see
Lex Luthor for a little while instead
what we find out is that the real goal
of Damian Wayne here was to basically
download the the complete security log
of LexCorp basically going through and
looking at all the video footage now
again this is one of the reasons why
Damian is so smart as one of the reasons
why he is so capable because Lex Luthor
one of the smartest men in the world did
not realize that Damian Wayne had hacked
into his system he didn't realize that
all he knew was that Damian Wayne just
some kid had gone through and planted a
whole bunch of bombs now again this is
also Damian Wayne using the fact that
Lex Luthor doesn't know who he is if Lex
Luthor had known who Damian Wayne was it
was probably a really good chance he
would have approached the situation
differently I mean the son of Batman
Batman's one of the smartest man if not
the smartest man in the DC Universe it
would have made sense if you would have
treated Damian Wayne with the same kind
of respect with the Garcias intellect
but regardless of how this event played
out the fact remains here that Damian
Wayne going through the footage of the
security logs basically ends up
realizing that there is a kid who broke
into the
the Laboratory of Lex Luthor and
basically stole something called the
Amazo armor now we'll get to that here
in a second because Amazo is a really
cool concept in DC it's one of the
coolest things they've done for quite
some time especially during Jeff Jones
running Justice League but the fact
remains here that going through and
looking at the video footage between
Damian Wayne intellect his resources and
in Superboy's abilities what the end of
finding out is that this kid is somebody
by the name of Reggie so of course
jumping on the Robin motorcycle because
you know as Damian why wouldn't have a
Robin motorcycle they trace the location
of Reggie back to a warehouse only to
find that the warehouse is basically
just filled with the dead bodies of what
looks like Reggie's family so this story
kind of borderlines on the idea of
things being somewhat dark and dangerous
while also maintaining kind of the fun
vibrant edge that makes super Sun so
cool now that's one of the interesting
things about this where Jonathan
basically says look I can't deal with
this these are dead bodies these are
beyond me you know I got to go we need
to call Batman Superman let the adults
handle this and Damian Wayne says no we
have to stay behind and investigate and
the to effectively part ways Jonathan
comes across a little girl in the woods
but both Jonathan and Damian are
basically attacked by their opposite
fathers you know or at least set apart
by their opposite fathers Superman and
Batman now of course what we find out
here is that these are essentially
androids these are not actually Batman
and Superman the fact remains here that
we end up having you know of course
Damian and Superboy you know taking on
their fathers respectively and that kind
of a thing but both of these androids
are essentially deactivated by this
young girl and this is when we start to
get the backstory of everything that's
essentially going on here and this is
when we start to get into the idea of
the Amazo virus now within the realm of
DC Comics the Amazo concept comes in two
forms there's the Amazo Android and then
there's the Amazo virus the amazing
Android was pretty straightforward he
was basically developed by a guy named
professor Ivo and the Amazo Android had
the ability to duplicate the powers of
the Justice League it simply just like
had all their powers so as was explained
here and in Super Sons is exactly how it
was for the most part Amazo was a
one-man Justice League the Flash's speed
Superman strength you know so on and so
forth with regards to the different
powers that existed with regards to the
Justice League now the Amazo virus was
something that was actually designed by
Lex Luthor for the purpose of
neutralizing the powers of metahumans
who were deemed to be too dangerous the
problem was
according to virtually every form of
every governing body in existence for
the most part it was deemed to be too
extreme it was deemed to be cruel and
unusual punishment and so in response it
was more or less shelved I mean it was
used a couple times but nothing ever
really came of it until a guy by the
name of Nathaniel
Tyron I think it is I'm not gonna swear
- his last name but he had basically
been tasked with killing Lex Luthor
screwed it up and then accidentally
released the Amazo virus and so what the
Amazo virus did is it basically began
bonding itself to hosts and giving
people powers you know if I kind of had
to make like a comparison we could go
with like the Amazo virus kind of be
like the equivalent of the Terrigen mist
so to speak the difference is that you
didn't you know you don't have to have a
pre-existing gene in order to be given
powers because of the amazing Amazo
virus the Amazo virus just gives you
abilities now what these abilities were
just dependent on people I mean
different people just manifested
different abilities arbitrarily there
was no guessing what a person's powers
were going to be you couldn't look at a
person's age and weight and height and
so on and so forth and say well that
person is probably going to have
telepathy it's just whatever power they
happen to get now for the most part
after a while the power simply just
began to dissipate people began to lose
them but there were some individuals who
kept them and the family of Reggie is
one of the families that kept those
powers the issue at this is that for the
most part their powers were largely
self-contained they were largely
isolated to themselves meaning that they
had like super-strength or they could
fly or something like that in the case
of Reggie he could duplicate himself and
whenever he duplicated himself each
duplicate had the same ability as all
the other versions so they were all
equals it wasn't like when he duplicated
himself his power began to decrease with
each duplicate so it's not like you know
he had two versions of himself and each
one had 50% of the total power it was
you know he duplicate himself and each
one of them have 100% of his total power
the problem with this was that Reggie
began to go awry and began to
effectively lose his mind and so what he
did is he actually started creating
these robotic duplicates of his family
and then just started routinely killing
his family all the time but the more he
began to devolve into the realm of
insanity the more he began to go about
feeling like a maze Oh Harlan in a maze
Oh tests and different things like that
and so what this did is it allowed him
to duplicate himself and then using the
Amazo armor allow him to duplicate the
powers of anybody that he comes into
contact with now that's a big difference
here he's almost like protege
Marvel Comics you know Protege had the
ability to duplicate the powers of
anybody as long as you saw them using
their powers anyone from a person with
super-strength all the way up to the
Living Tribunal he could just copy
whatever their abilities were
reality-warping telepathy telekinesis
the whole nine yards with Reggie he has
to be within the vicinity of a person in
order to duplicate their powers so it's
really more passive than anything else
he doesn't have to see Superboy flying
it doesn't have to see Superboy using
super-strength he just has to be around
him and then the Amazo suit will just
automatically duplicate those powers and
allow Reggie to use them now the reason
why this is so cool and the reason why
it matters so much is because this
presents a legitimate credible threat to
the world that the super Suns are going
to be dealing with and that's why this
was cool is because it would have been
very easy for Tomasi to just kind of
pawn it off and be like you're super
Suns all you want and they're going to
stop a bank robbery I mean it was
entirely possible that he could have
done that it would have drugged down the
narrative of the story and it wouldn't
have been nearly as good as it is right
now instead he gave us a kid that has
the ability to duplicate himself and
then took the Amazo armor and now has
all these duplicates running around that
have the ability to copy the powers of
others and effectively create a
super-powered army for himself and so
because of this what we also learn is
that this sister because she's basically
a robot she still has the Amazo powers
of herself of her normal human
counterpart mean she has the ability to
control machinery and so for the most
part these robotic forces of Roger
pretty much taken out pretty fast and
it's not a greatly cute ordeal but
they're taken out pretty quickly and of
course this results in Damian Wayne and
Superboy basically taking off now force
along the way while they're trying to
find Reggie of course what we end up
having is Damian Wayne is kind of
hijacking one of the cyborgs meddling
with his helmet but we don't really find
out what it is that they're doing
instead we still get like all these
references from Superboy Jonathan Kent
talking about the Teen Titans and
different things like that and that's
one of the funny things is because one
of the day questions people had when
super Sons was essentially launched and
when Jonathan Kent was introduced as the
son of Superman in the modern day the
question was why is he not on the team
Titans well the answer this given is by
Damian Wayne is that Jonathan since just
not old enough
it's the Teen Titans not the pre Teen
Titans and so once once Jonathan hits
like 13 or 14 years old then he'll
probably be inducted onto the team just
because Damian would be foolish not to
have the son of Superman on the Teen
Titans it seems like a stunt that he
would pull but he'd be full
to not do that and so of course with the
two of them being captured by Kidd Amazo
some of the because of the fact that the
powers of Jonathon come and go because
he doesn't have full control of his
faculties yet this inevitably leads to
basically Kidd Amazo does kind of
dumping the whole plan and talking about
everything that he's doing in his goal
to basically take over the world but
that's why this is so cool is because
with an army of robots that can
duplicate the powers of everybody that
they come across he could conceivably do
that he could literally take out the
Justice League and take out the Green
Lantern's if they arrived on earth and
could actually conquer the world this is
why Tomasi is out the way that he
basically ends this story is done so
well the reason this happens is because
of the fact that the robots can only
copy organic powers you know legitimate
powers meaning powers that are
inherently natural to a person or powers
that are bestowed on a person with Lex
Luthor it's not that way Lex Luthor
Superman suit is not designed using you
know Superman's genes it's not designed
using you know Kryptonian DNA it's
basically just a technological suit it's
a machinery and that's why it works is
because fully enough having is Lex
Luthor arriving onto the scene after
damian wayne had used that helmet to sin
lex a message and saying here is the kid
who's been breaking into LexCorp come
and get him and defeat this guy this kid
is not able to duplicate the powers of
lex luthor
because Lex Luthor had no powers he's
only just using a mechanized suit if he
had brought in
you know Superman then suddenly we would
have these amazing Oh bot with the full
power of Superman and Superman would
easily be defeated when five or six of
them maybe even ten or eleven of them
team up on him and that would be the end
of that the super sons would probably be
killed and in the world would just be
right for the picking from from from kid
Amazo
so again it's really really good
thinking on behalf of Tomasi in order to
give this story a legitimate out now of
course while Lex Luthor is dealing with
the forces of kid Amazo and kid Amazo
himself Jonathan and Damian you know get
the girl and her family out of there and
they really just kind of call it a day I
mean you know you end up having kid
Amazo who's ultimately defeated once it
begins recalling all these versions into
himself and the reason why I use
defeated is because of the fact that his
sister uses for control over machinery
to force the Amazo armor off of kid
Amazo
and so from here Reggie basically just
kind of begins to break down and lose
his mind now the explanation that's
given here by Tomasi is that Reggie's
just been splitting himself time and
time again the more he split himself the
more unde
he became and the more he stressed his
body's physical structure now that
actually makes sense that is an
explanation that makes sense within the
context of this story and the reason why
is because there's a litany of
superheroes all across the realm of
comics who can duplicate themselves
that's not new and none of them really
go insane by virtue of duplicating
themselves but that's because they have
training they've been doing it for some
real measure of time with Reggie he
doesn't have formal training he has
whatever you know whatever times he's
been doing it but he's kind of pushing
himself too hard too fast and because of
that his body does not know how to
handle the experience of being stretched
into so many versions of himself in such
an extreme way instead it's almost like
a rubber band eventually it'll just snap
back and when it does his mind will go
with it so Reggie isn't really killed so
much as he's just incapacitated and
that's really the end of that you know
while Lex Luthor is kind of talking to
this young girl and saying look we'll
find you a home we'll find you a place
to stay and we'll get you on the road to
becoming a legitimate superhero given
your ability to control machinery Damian
Wayne and Jonathan can't bail out they
take off they go home and it's really
kind of funny because once they get back
to Jonathan Kent's house they have to
deal with the most formidable enemy
which is a very angry mom so we're not
being said guys we are going to bring
this video to an end in the next video
we will pick up with the aftermath of
super Sons vol 1 there we go we will
pick up with the aftermath of this story
but if you guys are new here to come
this explained make sure you guys have
two sub button to become part of the
robb cork you guys enjoyed this video
make sure you drop a like and I will
catch you all later please
[Music]